le plus important pour préparer les
fêtes d'abord les fêtes il faut les
faire
la vie la vie c'est c'est de la routine
et des fêtes vous avez déjà dit sur ce
plateau la meilleure chose à faire c'est
ça c'est une bonne routine toutes les
semaines et puis de temps en temps des
exceptions c'est que d'ailleurs comme ça
qu'on vivait il y a quelques milliers
d'années je sais moi toutes les
religions sont centrées autour des repas
et c'est quoi son groupe les fêtes avec
les religions c'est avec les repas et le
reste du temps et ben on se soit si on
n'a pas beaucoup de moyens on se
contente de ce qu'on a soit si on a des
moyens on fait justement attention pour
restreindre parce qu'aujourd'hui vous
avez des plates faites tous les jours
moi je suis une génération ou le saumon
fumé c'était le 31 décembre aujourd'hui
vous allez dans tous les supermarchés
vous avez un congélateur en sortie de de
enfin un réfrigérateur en sortie de près
des caisses avec le saumon c'est facile
bien sûr on fait ça un bout de pain un
peu de crème fraîche et hop c'est fini
c'est du gras sur du gras avec du pain
du sucre alors bravo
de temps en temps ça n'a rien de
catastrophique ça passe faut jamais dire
jamais en nutrition si on fait alors
c'est quelqu'un qui fait beaucoup de
sport est-ce qu'il peut manger plus que
ça fait beaucoup de paddle par exemple
alors pour moi
voilà quand on mange ça on a encore
combien de sport après derrière non non
c'est pas c'est pas comme ça qu'il faut
faire comme ça aide pas à maigrir ça
permet de faire quelque chose d'énorme
ça augmente la masse musculaire il faut
savoir que pendant qu'on se parle chaque
kilo de vos muscles brûle 30 calories
par jour voilà je suis une belle
au repos voilà vous êtes au repos votre
masse musculaire c'est 30 calories par
jour donc en fait quand vous quand vous
montez votre masse musculaire quand vous
faites de l'exercice vous allez
augmenter ce qu'on appelle le
métabolisme de base c'est ça
c'est-à-dire celui qu'on brûle les
calories votre empreinte carbone
c'est-à-dire que vous brûlez ça à
l'arrêt sans bouger donc vous comprenez
bien que si vous augmentez même d'un
kilo ou de 2 kg votre masse musculaire
vous allez augmenter le fait de brûler
donc 60 calories pour 2 kg par jour sans
bouger vous multipliez par une semaine
et bien voilà vous avez 420 calories qui
sont brûlées sans rien faire en fait le
musculation
le sport le cardio ça permet de ne pas
grossir ça permet pas de maigrir c'est
ça voilà c'est ça
quand on en fait trop il faut pas
oublier que le sport donne faim ah ouais
donc on peut avoir bonne conscience et
après on se dit de toute façon j'ai fait
du sport je vais manger donc on augmente
tout doucement les quantités de voilà et
puis bien entendu ça c'est vrai pour des
adultes c'est pas vrai pour pour les
ados ou pour les enfants je rappelle que
les conseils nutritionnels pour les
adultes ne valent pas pour les enfants
les enfants sont en pleine croissance
eux ils ont ils ont besoin de grandir
ils ont besoin de prendre de la masse
alors que quand on a nos âges en tout
cas le mien il faut justement faire un
petit peu attention vous êtes magnifique
c'est qu'on fait le qualitatif faut pas
faire le quantitatif qu'est-ce que vous
avez à la maison à lui offrir si vous
avez des choses avec des calories vides
et ben à ce moment-là qu'il y a beaucoup
d'enfants mais qu'il y a que des
bouteilles de l'alcool
j'avoue hier j'ai mangé un petit caca
de chips ou un paquet voilà mais quand
même ouais le problème
est-ce que vous faites des écarts parce
que quand on voit Delphine tu peux
manger ce que tu veux tôt bien tu euh
oui je fais je fais beaucoup d'écart
mais vu que j'ai une routine quand même
constante et généralement je jeûne le
matin et le soir quand je peux
pas
faire le ramadan
non mais perpétuel en fait
vous permet vraiment de stabiliser le
poids et même parfois un peu de de
perdre un tout petit peu alors le jeûne
intermittent il y a un vrai débat
là-dessus il y a des il y a des pour il
y a des contre la réalité c'est que ça
dépend aussi de l'âge la personne voilà
à votre âge les choses sont un peu
différente parce que vous vous souvenez
de non vous souvenez du fait que il y a
des gens qui sont des chaudières et pas
d'autres
[Rires]
l'hérédité nous sommes hérédités nous
sommes les enfants de nos parents nos
grands-parents nous aimeraient
grands-parents si vous avez dans la
famille
obèses ou des grands-parents obèses les
risques d'être obèses sont importants si
vous avez on sait qu'aujourd'hui si vous
avez un parent diabétique de type 2 vous
aurez entre 50 et 70% de risque d'être
diabétiques de type 2 donc ça veut dire
que vous pouvez pas donner des conseils
à tout le monde comme ça ça dépend des
individus et on est hérédité il y a
l'hérédité c'est pour ça il faut pas
culpabiliser les gens faut pas quand on
voit un ado qui obèse faut pas le dire
oui il est ado parce que il est obèse
parce qu'il mange c'est pas comme ça que
ça marche c'est l'hérité moi je ne
connais pas d'obèse je ne connais pas
d'obèse qui sont des gens négligés qui
mangent comme ça parce que non non ce
sont des gens qui ont une génétique et
ils vivent ils doivent vivre
malheureusement avec cette génétique il
y a des solutions aujourd'hui en tout
cas il faut le dire il faut arrêter de
culpabiliser là-dessus voilà mais pour
revenir au fait pour revenir au fait
préparer les fêtes ça va être quoi
préparer les fêtes
de l'exercice préparer les fêtes c'est
faire de l'exercice c'est bien
s'hydrater c'est pas se culpabiliser et
surtout
gérer les quantités il vaut mieux avoir
la qualité que la quantité même si
aujourd'hui c'est difficile parce que la
qualité ça coûte cher parce que moi j'ai
déjà accélérations des fois c'est à dire
c'est à dire que j'arrive tu vois je
peux prendre plein de trucs comme ça tu
vois
tu me mets une boîte de un truc un peu
l'escargot là je les mange tous alors ça
c'est lié à plusieurs facteurs le
premier à votre éducation
attention notre éducation c'est que la
mer vis-à-vis de l'enfant nourrir son
enfant c'est fondamental et donc finis
ton assiette pour faire plaisir à maman
ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire n'écoute
pas tes signaux de satiété c'est ça
parce que tu dois me faire plaisir voilà
et ça alors c'est très bienveillant de
la part de la maman mais le problème
c'est que du coup vous allez avoir
toujours l'attitude je finis lassiette
de je finis la boîte fini je finis le
paquet de chips je fais et ça il faut
apprendre malheureusement il faut
apprendre à nos enfants à jeter c'est ça
c'est ça c'est ça nos corps ne sont pas
des poubelles
non mais c'est vrai vous avez raison et
le champagne le champagne alors sur le
choix c'est quoi pour les fêtes là parce
que le champagne franchement vous pouvez
prendre une à deux coupes de champagne
si vous avez les moyens prenez du
millésimés parce que le champagne
millésimé a moins de sucre que le
champagne classique
mais vous avez par exemple les
millésimés ils ont à peu près trois à
quatre pour cent de sucre alors que les
non millésimés à 10 à 12%
aujourd'hui aujourd'hui notre problème
c'est que le budget alimentaire va nous
coûter cher parce qu'en fait on a fait
de la productivité de masse nos
agriculteurs très bien travaillés ils
ont fait de la production ils ont baissé
les coups il y a des intermédiaires qui
se sont mis les supermarchés les hyper
qui ont pris leur marge là-dessus en
fait on a on a inondé le monde avec de
l'alimentaire et paradoxalement on l'a
fait à un moment il fallait pas c'est à
dire que les Français ont vécu la guerre
ils avaient pas de beurre pas de lait
pas de viande pas de plaisir et dans les
années 50 la productivité
agroalimentaire a augmenté et on avait
envie de tout ça et on ne sait lâcher
sur le sucre lâcher sur le les graisses
lâcher sur la viande lâcher surtout
alors qu'avant il y avait une espèce de
régulation moi je me souviens que quand
ma mère allait chez le boucher et disait
voilà je veux un gigot pour jouer un
gigot pour 6 nous étions 6 à la maison
et ben c'est lui avec le couteau je sais
pas si vous voyez ce geste il prend
aujourd'hui vous allez dans un
supermarché pour le prix de ce que vous
donnez le boucher vous en avez pour 12
et nous sommes dans une civilisation où
ne nous jetons nous jetons rien c'est à
dire qu'en fait s'il reste du gigot va
le manger si vous achetez les packs de
yaourt par 24 vous les mangerez donc
c'est devenu totalement paradoxal mais
ça c'est un vrai problème
aujourd'hui c'est important parce que
comme ça si vous faites vos courses
souvent vous avez du frais vous avez du
bio
quand vous dites je veux perdre du poids
ça veut dire je veux faire attention à
mon corps parce que vous savez vous
savez tout ce qu'elles sont les
conséquences d'un surpoids le diabète
les problèmes articulaires les problèmes
respiratoires donc pour ça faire
attention à soi c'est consacrer un peu
de temps et il y a deux temps importants
premier c'est faire ses courses
s'occuper de ce qu'on mange c'est ça ou
en tout cas le sous-traiter à quelqu'un
de confiance
c'est très bien mais bon c'est un peu
économiquement bien sûr et deuxièmement
c'est faire de l'exercice faire de
l'exercice comme un métier et là on est
dans le réveillon parce que si vous
faites de l'exercice comme un métier
faire de réveillon Noël jour de l'an
mais l'organisme il le verra même le
verra même pas mais non
faites attention à l'alcool surtout si
vous si vous roulez après je bois pas
arrêtons ce truc pour moi je porte voilà
faites attention l'alcool restez plutôt
dormir
faites attention aussi aux charges de
sucre parce que souvent quand on a une
grosse charge de sucre et qu'on en a pas
l'habitude on est très somnolans après
c'est ça et on n'est pas bien donc voilà
il faut alors il y a un petit un petit
truc et ficelle que je vous donne ah ça
c'est pour les grands repas c'est
utilisé au Moyen-Orient et au Maghreb
c'est le café blanc le café blanc le
café blanc prenez de l'eau chaude et
vous mettez une cuillère à café ou à
soupe de de fleur d'oranger ah pas mal
parce que Mazar bravo et d'ailleurs
c'est tradition en Tunisie par exemple
sur et pourquoi parce que c'est hyper
colérétique et hyper collagogue alors ça
c'est des ça veut dire qu'en gros vous
faites plus de bile pour digérer et la
bile il colle à gauche que la vésicule
la lâche parce qu'il faut que la
vésicule à l'âge souvent quand on mange
gras on a un problème on a mal ici on a
mal au fond c'est ça c'est le foie ne
fait jamais mal à la fois vésicule et
j'en ai plus la vision quand la vésicule
fait mal faut consulter son médecin donc
il faut boire ça à la fin du repas à la
fin du repas vous buvez ça d'ailleurs
les Libanais c'est le café blanc c'est
du Liban comme beaucoup de choses
c'est la fleur d'oranger même
l'après-midi si vous voulez vous pouvez
après le repas vous faire un gros mug
comme ça d'eau chaude avec de fleur
d'oranger d'autres ajoute du miel ça
c'est mais ça c'est vraiment une boisson
incroyable ça c'est bien ça c'est bien
je vais le faire ça tu vois et donc il
faut faire ses courses
et faire du sport c'est ça
pour le foie quoi ce que le foie il a
une caractéristique incroyable comme
nous venons de d'une période où
franchement manger n'importe quoi le
foie c'est le filtre c'est lui qui
filtre tout il filtre tout et donc à
l'époque dans les cavernes vous pouvez
sortir manger quelques petits trucs qui
étaient dehors c'était l'hiver donc
c'était il y avait des bactéries c'était
pas terrible c'est machin voilà et donc
on a un foie surdimensionné pour nous
surdimensionnel et donc son sa capacité
à lui-même à se dégraisser parce qu'on a
le foie gras il faut pas la voir manger
mais faut pas l'avoir
à se dégraisser elle est dépendante du
débit cardiaque plus vous augmentez le
débit cardiaque plus le foie va se
détoxifier c'est ça donc c'est pour ça
qu'on recommande de faire l'exercice
bien sûr c'est pas uniquement pour les
muscles ça fait tourner le sang et le
foie lui il va pouvoir se détoxifier
voilà Valérie Benaim malgré tout
aujourd'hui il y a plein de familles
recomposées et donc on fait plusieurs
repas et pas que deux parce qu'il faut
aller dans la belle famille ou etc
est-ce que il faut par exemple dans
toujours off pendant ces 15 jours de
vacances ce jour off il faut peut-être
ne pas manger ou boire des bouillons
faire des trucs
c'est à dire que ce que vous pouvez
faire si vous avez envie de vous
préparer à ces deux jours c'est faire ce
qu'on appelle un petit génie Drick
boire des bouillons plutôt liquide
beaucoup beaucoup
et à ce moment-là vous allez préparer
votre vous savez que vous allez voir une
grosse charge cela étant dit une charge
c'est vraiment une charge c'est à dire
que votre organisme pour lui c'est une
agression quand vous le chargez avec du
sucre et du gras vous l'agressez c'est
pas très compliqué et est-ce que c'est
bien les essais il y a des il y a des
gens qui vendent des programmes minceur
des escrocs pour perdre du poids en
quelques jours ferme ta gueule
ça c'est une fille est-ce que
les gens qui les gens qui vendent ça moi
je considère pas regarder à droite en
direction
je crois que ce soit des escrocs
[Rires]
je pense pas que ce soit des Esco je
pense qu'à partir du moment où quelqu'un
a envie de s'occuper de lui il va se
connecter sur quelque chose ou aller
voir un médecin ou aller voir un
nutritionniste ou aller voir une
personne le simple fait le simple fait
de vouloir le faire ça change déjà après
il y a des théories il y a celui qui va
manger ça qui va manger ça il y a
plusieurs chemins pour aboutir un truc
il y a pas la pierre philosophale et le
Messie nutritionniste n'existe pas
louche la méthode est pas tout détox
minceur grâce au foie